that did it
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the show that
wanted to be more attractive so we
swallowed a bunch of magnets painful
joke most certainly but not nearly as
painful as those magnets coming out the
other end
speaking of magnets let's talk better
call Saul the sequel prequel series to
one of televisions greatest shows
Breaking Bad the show flashes back six
years before Walter White starts up his
meth cookery to tell the story of how a
young lawyer with the best of intentions
named Jimmy McGill becomes the sleazy
defender of criminals Saul Goodman sadly
not many people are watching it and
certainly not many of you who watch this
show are watching it but heck every once
in a while I need to take a break from
making half-baked superhero theories to
introduce you to a show that is
definitely worth your time let me tell
you better call Saul is definitely one
of those admittedly it's slow like
really slow like we're at the end of
season three and not a whole lot has
happened slow it's also quiet like
really quiet like long sequences of the
show happened in complete silence quiet
but it is one of the most beautifully
shot deeply moving explorations of
character and relationships ever to be
put on a TV screen these people feel
brutally real both for the good and for
the bad the relationships feel lived in
and for fans of Breaking Bad it gets you
to question everything that you thought
you knew about the characters from that
series I mean I hated hated Gus fring
and Breaking Bad he was like my Joffrey
in Game of Thrones
I could not wait for this guy to die and
in better call Saul I am rooting so hard
for him to win someone who I know full
well goes on to do awful awful awful
horrific things that is how good this
show is so do yourself a favor the first
two seasons are on Netflix right now go
binge um and then pirate your way
through season three you do it for three
reasons one the show is great two it'll
help ensure that the show gets a fourth
season and three at least then this
video may not horrendously underperform
ad pocalypse guys it's a real thing but
every once in a while you gotta do
something for art's sake anyway whether
you've seen the show or not the reason
I'm dedicating a full episode
to it today when I could be covering
Wonder Woman or Kars 3 or guardians 2 or
pirates or literally any other thing
that I could possibly be covering that
will absolutely give me more views and
definitely more ad revenue is that it
poses a fascinating science question
that I think you all will enjoy so to
get you up Jimmy McGill and Chuck McGill
are brothers lawyers and deceivers
although those last you might be a bit
redundant am i right up top anyway one
of Chuck's defining character features
is that he's supposedly allergic to
electricity anything that produces
electromagnetic radiation causes him
discomfort and pain in the show's own
words this illness what does it feel
like there's a tightness in my chest
difficulty breathing and pain in fact
he's so sensitive to it that he requires
that all the lights be shut off in all
watches and cellphones get left outside
whenever he enters a room his house is
like a dark cave lit by lanterns and if
he ever does have to interact with
electricity he wears a space blanket to
protect him what's a space blanket you
asked compact mylar sheets they insulate
and protect against mild electromagnetic
radiation it's like a human Jiffy Pop
anyway Chuck's condition has always been
a bit questionable but it really pays
off in the incredible season 3 episode
chicanery to give you context Jimmy
cares for Chuck Chuck screws over Jimmy
Jimmy screws over Chuck in return Chuck
takes Jimmy to courts and it seemed
court during Jimmy's cross-examination
of Chuck when we see the following so if
I had a small battery safe from a watch
or something and I got too close to you
close to your skin you'd know I would
feel it yes intensity drops off with
distance per the inverse square law
Jimmy then asks can you tell us where
the nearest source is right now Jimmy do
you have something in your pocket but no
it's chuck with something in his pocket
Jimmy asks Chuck to reach into his own
breast pocket revealing a battery that
Jimmy had planted on him Chuck
immediately drops the battery and
recoils as Jimmy grabs it shoves it into
his phone and proves that the thing was
charged the whole time and the internet
turned electric which in retrospect
probably sent some discomfort Chuck's
way debating about whether or not
unplugged batteries draw any current and
therefore produce any electromagnetic
radiation chuck should have recoiled
from an unplugged battery there's no
current there no cellphone batteries are
drawing a tiny bit of current but it's
next to none the exit signs in the room
could be giving off stronger signals
actually all of this is irrelevant
because he's been faking it the whole
time and on and on and on so loyal
theorists my question today can you
actually be allergic to electricity is
the fact that batteries don't emit a
whole lot of electromagnetic radiation
an oversight on the part of the writers
is Chuck actually sick or has he been
faking his illness the entire time and
what does any of this mean for the
future of the series because let me tell
you the scientific answer to this
question actually reveals a lot about
this character and where he's headed to
next so to truly answer this question we
have to look all the way back to the
beginning since the character of chuck
was first introduced in Episode one of
better call Saul viewers have speculated
that he might be faking his condition
and so it sounds elaborate faking a
medical condition is absolutely the type
of thing that Chuck would and could pull
off I mean this is a guy who in his
desire to revoke Jimmy's legal license
exaggerated his illness to lure Jimmy
into confessing a crime on tape then
stages himself accidentally letting
someone else hear that confession
counting on the fact that the person
would then go back and tell Jimmy
causing Jimmy to break into his house
and destroy the tape in front of two
witnesses that chuck it just so happened
to plant there for a couple days for
just such an occasion I mean that is
like some saw levels of puppeteering
other people or convenient plot
loopholes but whatever that being said
the show has also had several scenes
where we see the world from Chuck's
point of view like the one that we used
at the top of this episode and the way
that these scenes are shot and edited it
seems to confirm that electricity
genuinely causes Chuck pain and distress
there's no one around watching him and
yet he's still acting weird so the best
place to start seems to be answering the
question can a person truly be allergic
to electricity
well the idea isn't something that was
just made up by the writers there are
actual people out there who claim to
experience some sort of adverse reaction
to electronics first written about back
in the 80s this condition has since been
dubbed electromagnetic hypersensitivity
or EHS and according to several polls
taken it's been estimated that as high
as four percent of the population
claimed experience it to some degree
symptoms can be a
mild is tingling skin and fatigue or as
severe as full-blown migraines and heart
palpitations but just because people say
they have an illness doesn't necessarily
make it true is there any scientific
data to back this stuff up enter project
nemesis that's seriously its name like
something straight out of resident evil
project nemesis how badass must you feel
working on a project named nemesis these
researchers just they needed something
cool to do with their lives and they're
like alright let's call this like the
coolest name ever anyway as a part of
project nemesis scientists made boxes
that when turned on would generate an
electromagnetic field the idea was to
place these boxes underneath the beds of
their subjects on some nights the box
would turn on and generate a field and
on other nights it would stay off and do
nothing as part of the experiment they
also made other boxes that looked
identical to the electromagnetic field
generators except they were dummy boxes
that never turned on now each subject
had a dummy box underneath one side of
their bed and a live box on the other
side to see if the subjects ever favored
sleeping on one side or the other on
nights of the live box turned on at the
end of the experiment
there weren't any noticeable physical
effects like heavier breathing or faster
heart rates let six of the 35 subjects
did consistently switch which side of
the bed they slept on whenever the
device was turned on interesting results
to be sure but certainly not the most
definitive in a follow-on test
researchers had subjects sit in a booth
underneath an electric coil and subjects
were then asked to tell the researchers
whether that coil was on or off seven
out of the sixty-three performed better
than chance but still hardly the
electrifying results that they were
looking for so to put the issue to bed
we read a 182 page research review
that's right a hundred and eighty-two
pages of this stuff for you guys in this
episode that's like longer and more
boring than the old man in the sea and
we all know how I feel about that book
182 pages of the stuff that was put out
by the World Health Organization which
reviewed not only these studies but also
30 others related to electromagnetic
hypersensitivity the paper concluded
that of those studies only 7 showed any
evidence of EHS existing at all and of
seven who weren't able to be repeated
another two contradicted each other and
the last three seem to be the result of
statistical errors well done well done
science well done take a bow
long story short the research points to
this being a made-up condition which
would seem to imply that the people who
say that they're allergic to electricity
are faking and that would explain some
of what we see in the show in episode 5
of season 1 Chuck is hospitalized he
remains unresponsive until all the
electricity is shut off in his room
whereupon he's able to finally talk and
explain his condition to the doctor
seems legit right but here's the thing
while he's talking the good doctor
secretly turns his medical bet on and he
doesn't seem to notice baker alert we
got an incoming report of a baker it's
the same story with the battery in the
courtroom scene from season 3 Chuck is
absolutely fine until he pulls the
battery out of his pocket and sees it at
which point only then does he flip out
and toss it away obviously faking his
reaction but then in the next episode
Chuck alone in his house after being
disproven in court grabs hold of a
battery which doesn't put out a whole
lot of e/m radiation and yet it still
seems like it's causing him problems why
would he keep up the act if he knows
he's alone and not being watched and in
real life why would so many people
report having such severe reactions to
electricity when the research doesn't
seem to back it up it all seems so
contradictory and that's because it is
the explanation for all of these bizarre
symptoms and contradictory research lies
in two words the nocebo and sorry it's
technically three words forgot to count
the rewind to the dramatic reveal music
the solution lies in three words the
nocebo effect now I'm sure you've all
heard about the placebo effect where
somebody has a headache
you give them fake medicine tell them
it's real medicine and voila
their headache is cure and despite it
being the medical equivalent of an
Altoid I don't care how curiously strong
it was it ain't doing diddly for my
migraine
well the nocebo effect is very similar
you give somebody a fake pill tell them
it has sir
side effects and what do you know they
start manifesting those same effects
even though the pill is fake in other
words if a patient believes something
harmless can actually harm them
oftentimes they'll actually experience
real pain and that's what's happening
with Chuck isn't allergic to electricity
but he thinks he is and that's enough to
cause the pain and discomfort we watch
him go through every time he's
confronted with electromagnetic waves or
at least something he thinks emits
electromagnetic waves and this in turn
explains everything that we see happen
on the show remember that pivotal
courtroom battery scene viewers were
upset by the scene because a charged
battery shouldn't give off a significant
amount of electromagnetic radiation
unless it's plugged in they called this
a plot hole or an oversight but it was
totally intentional Chuck's condition is
psychosomatic it doesn't matter whether
or not unplugged batteries give off
electromagnetic waves at all all that
matters is that Chuck thinks they do the
battery doesn't hurt him until he sees
it he's not faking it he actually feels
pain in that moment but it's not from
anything the battery is or isn't
emitting it's from his brain thinking
the battery is emitting something
that'll harm him I mean if you took this
to its logical extreme if Chuck thought
that asparagus gave off diem radiation
he'd be hurting every time he went
through the veggie stand of his local
grocery that's also why in that season
one episode he isn't threatened by the
hospital bed he doesn't know it's on and
thus his brain doesn't think there's
anything in the room that could be
causing him harm as a result he feels
nothing now what all of this means for
the rest of the show is really
interesting remember project emesis I
mean how could you forget it's still the
coolest name for a research project ever
one of the most interesting findings is
that subjects who claim to be harmed by
electricity notice that their symptoms
lessened after taking and failing one of
the Nemesis tests suddenly their belief
in the condition was threatened by proof
that
weren't actually feeling anything real
that it was all in their head and as a
result their symptoms started to weaken
according to the paper itself whoa
this shift is an indicator that EHS can
be unlearned by experiencing EMF
exposure which does not induce symptoms
just like Chuck and the courtroom
battery scene the battery incident
wasn't an oversight or some plot hole it
was very intentionally put there by
writers who had clearly done their
homework towards the end of season 3
episode 6 we see Chuck walked to a pay
phone to call dr. Cruz the same doctor
that secretly turned on his medical bed
two seasons earlier given that Chuck has
just been given evidence that his
condition is all in his head it makes
sense that he'd now be able to venture
further from his house under more
intense lights his symptoms are
weakening this perfectly aligns with the
Nemesis findings what's more is that
this means that chuck is finally seeking
help for his real but kind not real
condition he's getting stronger and like
any monster growing in power who knows
how threatening he'll become to our hero
Jimmy once he's broken free from his
very real get very imaginary electric
fence only time and season four will
tell provided the show gets a season
four which is why you gotta go watch it
right now
cuz look at how awesome this show is
anyway remember that's just a theory a
film theory and cuts
if you don't smash that subscribe button
on screen right now in the next three
seconds you'll experience an
electromagnetic tingle running through
your spine three two one
did you feel it you're still here did
you feel it electromagnetism running
through you and hey if you're a fan of
either better call Saul or Breaking Bad
make sure that you've checked out my
theory over here on screen right now of
how Walter white could have technically
survived the series finale of Breaking
Bad it's a good one click it so now if
you'll excuse me I need to go and binge
watch Breaking Bad from the beginning
because damn that was a great show oh so
good alright I'm gonna go watch it click
the subscribe button otherwise you're
gonna keep feeling that electromagnetic
tingle just sayin and I will see you all
next week
comets Chuck go to Jeffrey Tucker for
jimmy chuck could chuck wood nailed it
[Music]